on va démarrer avec le lion vous avez
une minute pour trouver kg lyon je veux
pas prêt d alice new secondes si vous
tombez nez aux téléspectateurs un
smartphone cette année comme en irak est
à torse alors le lion a toujours
savamment chéri d'amour se contente de
voir on ne sait pas mais il est ceinture
noire de coups de fouet avant de
s'amuser de chanteurs ligne que vous
êtes chanteur non comédiens humoristes
n'ont pas apporté les we call et bien et
comédien non oui c'est sûr tous deux en
france deux noms féminins
sur ces huit n'ont pas être peut-être un
jour peut-être vous avez toujours une
émission en cours ah oui sur celui qui
l'a tué était sur scène est aussi animé
toujours jeune artiste de 50 ans
ah oui il fait beaucoup moins sur m6 non
[Musique]
cyril hanouna en droit de faire je sais
à temps d'attenté je vous donne un
deuxième indice je sais alors y c'est
pascal le grand frère pascal soetens
ouais j'ai dit eh bien c'est oscar est
ce que c'est parce qu'elles se taisent
ils avaient délimité minutes et terminé
est ce que c'est parce qu'elle se taise
[Applaudissements]
merci je voudrais dire pascal tu as une
chaîne youtube qui cartonne oui c'est
vrai on a créé ça il ya pas très
longtemps il ya trois mois avait
qualifié pascal jmc châssis millions de
vues sur sa chaîne c'est vrai quelques
mois et alors il raconte tout ça parle
de père écoute je fais quelque chose de
différent par rapport à ce qu'on que
deux mois et j'appelle et du coup on a
créé il ya trois mois on s'amuse bien
c'est quelque chose de complètement
différent
je m'éclate et je montre une autre
facette de moi en fait le côté un peu
marrant et je tiens je montre jamais
d'ailleurs je voudrais dire un truc sur
pascal pascal c'est un mec
extraordinaire si je sais que tu suis
les familles tchadiennes vanessa d'eau
et où la tuerie wiba d'ailleurs tiens je
parlais avec gildas 1 le marseillais qui
je les remplis à 15 on est alors passé
plusieurs ils font appel c'est aussi la
ciotat énormité quoi maintenant et bien
aujourd'hui une petite fille ça fait dix
ans qu'ils axent accompagner tout va
bien alors est ce que tu veux pas qu'on
va c'est un truc un jour dans des bains
péjorant vendredi j'ai rien qu'on fasse
un truc on revoit toutes les scènes à
minutes les gars les plus écoutés ils
nous disent qu'ils sont devenus fous tu
me le faire on passe en revue avec
plusieurs ont fait pas ce vendredi là le
vendredi d'après ben je bloque à l'essai
fait aller chez fait mais c est la vie
qu'ils étaient moins forts que vous je
ne le crois pas ah ouais bah par contre
vous c'est sûr que c'est plus fort que
moi
c'est pas parce que nous avons fait
entrer le corry al ghoreir le gorille
attention qui l autorise les semaines à
tokyo
je vous le dis alors question elle vous
sportif mais vous sportifs n'ont
amélioré et vous chanteur oui tout faire
enfin partie d'un duo ah oui non non
vous pouvez donner deux jours britney
spears tout ça allait déraper
bon vous pensez que c'est là d'où notre
jeune homme d'à non pas du tout non bon
bah y'a pas longtemps la caisse car est
ce que vous avez fait un tube ya pas
très longtemps louis et c'est pour ça
qu'ils le chef de l'état pense à tous
les gens qui portent à théo l'arabe on
regarde vous dit
[Applaudissements]
oui
je jouais poursuivre pour atteindre
merci de me recevoir
j'adore jetant grossi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et ça va monter haut
ça va ça marche pour toi ouais super
j'adore et je suis ton gros chipolatas
celle de mettre tous les jours toute la
soirée qu'une fois qu'elle la haye la
chipolata une fois que tu là impossible
de le ressortir
non mais c'est un les cherry hill et je
lui fais attention mais attention il y
en a quatre
ce soir on les efforts maintenant je
sais qu'il fait chez vous d'éléphants
l'éléphant l'effort l'effort s'était
alors dit rien c'est un comédien
chanteur il est nourri d'un prêt à cinq
copains on vous donne la grille fouillé
ouais ça court pas moi ouais c'est un
chanteur qui fait maury de salut maori
mais non non il est drôle et au recteur
paul est un producteur télé non center
je vous donne à la disent à quoi
agriculteurs non pourquoi vous dites ça
parce qu'elle a parlé de l'amour est
dans le pré donc du coup ça m'a fait
penser agriculteurs ah oui à 6 cm
wilson agriculteurs ce qui s'est passé
[Musique]
non
c'est bien thierry d'abord oui ça va à
la fois tu déjà fait flipper ton
histoire ça va mettre le voisin
l'argovien demain je vais amener la
trompe pas ce que lui faire peur non
c'est vrai parce que tu as et a agressé
donc ça va mieux là oui mais je pense
qu'il a compris
bon c'est bon ouais sinon je ramène
déguisements à demain intervenez aussi
fort qu'à le grand frère je vois votre
voisin tu l'auras pascal le grand frère
était au lavabo très chaud j'attendrai
le crocodile vous savez mieux payés que
la rencontre en koni grob sur le pont
il fait très chaud ce plateau il faut
trouver très vite à une chaleur ce
plateau cocody est ce que ibrahima de ce
soir peut-être le crocodile ayant
nathalie marqué que le ver gens disent
qu'on va parler de jean pierre pernaut
dans un instant donc elle est
intervenante chronique du salut et je
laime je voulais dire j'aime cette
personne attention c'est une immense
star ça va vous faire extrêmement
plaisir à vous avoue à tout le monde ici
une minute pour trouver ces parties
toutes les questions concernant
l'animateur télé
merci aussi à bernis il ay la wii mais
c'est un très gros oui on est star ces
acteurs est ce que vous êtes un acteur
oui mais est-ce que vous avez tourné
vers les productions américaines
oui oui et c est ce que vous avez un
lien de parenté avec quelqu'un sur le
plateau on parie la pente de bien laver
à quoi vous avez reconnu sa démarche
comptez entre c'est vrai oui
wemmel vous êtes vous animé un grand jeu
samedi soir sont là deux alors moi je
vous dire comme les autres earl woods
team clos vous avez 30 secondes pour
trouver qui si vous avez toutes les
questions possibles une pause par
rapport à la démarche
jean pierre castaldi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quelques jours longtemps la matinale
effectuée avons tiré les pêcheurs et un
camion se déshabiller non non non
surtout pas non mais faut quand même que
je le dise me sens et ça non je suis
trop du nom mais c'est bon il est il est
vacciné mon frère et moi je vais mettre
à côté de lui parce que kim envoyé par
med son livre le prix talent de ça mais
parce que j'ai pas passée il peut
envoyer à teaser du soir ouais à 3
heures du matin j'étais dessus le
lendemain matin je me suis levé à 6h30
pour le finir à 11 heures je l'appelais
il a écrit un magnifique livre
bravo c'est bouleversé scientifiquement
et présentées sur youtube voilà
l'origine attention tout ému bah moi tu
vois si c'est que dès que j'ai mon père
sur un plateau c'est toujours l'émotion
parce que je me suis le petit garçon est
né sur le pouce non papa oui agréable
malgré son vieil âge et mon émoi
la mode est aussi un important soutien
de mon père parce que il a été sobre se
faire vacciner et je voulais passer le
message
je suis allé il avoue sceptiques il a
fait voilà pas du tout leurs ya rien du
tout et bien du tout sinon il serait pas
là
jean pierre est ce que ça va parce que
c'est dur pour les comédiens ce moment
il nous en parle pas on va pas pleurer
avoir pas pleurer c'est vrai que
d'autres gens qui jouent contre nous
mais là vraiment un an ça fait beaucoup
beaucoup moins parce que moi on va
arrêter une tournée une pièce à paris
qui marchait plus près ce que non tu
vois c'est vraiment il n'ya pas de
travail c'est sa ronde à quelques
tournages évidemment mais au théâtre il
y à que dalle
on sait même pas si au moins tout on va
pouvoir jouer pour les festivals c'est
pas sûr encore ce que je peux vous dire
c'est qu'à partir de septembre
normalement je suis en tournée avec une
pièce s'appelle les beaux-pères avec
stevie nicks tv avec si on a fait le
tournage du le pitch de la pièce
d'ayasse le merdier c'est très très
drôle et ben et jean pierre tu sais
qu'on t'aime tu viens de voir quand tu
veux tu as été un amour et benjamas que
tom qui truc à dire à ton papa agenais
mon père et fils est fabuleuse des faits
encore tomber dans ces travers du jeu
très peur de lui et c'est vrai qu'il ne
dira pas mais c'est vrai que pour tous
les intermittents et oui mais voilà
c'est très très très compliqué parce que
c'est bien c'est qu'on n'ait pas fait
d'abord pour être inactif ça ça va ça m
enfermer tu vois je voulais vraiment
enfermé quoi tu peux pas sortir
tu peux pas déjeuné avec un pote voix
oui c'est vraiment terrible tu peux même
pas boire un café chez toi tu as ta
femme qui télétravaillent ta fille qui
fait des études montrent que facebook
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]